hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming true with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to be
talking about is how to find the area of
a segment in a circle so when we talk
about segments we're not talking about
segment lengths we're actually talking
about this area right here so when you
draw a sector okay which is like a slice
or a section of a circle like a pizza
slice right and if you subtract off this
triangle here you're going to be left
with this area which is called a segment
so I'll just draw this again so you can
see it real quickly basically what we
have is we have a circle and then you
have the center of the circle right
there you have a triangle like so and if
you take these two points okay where the
radius intersects the circle and you
connect those two points with a chord
okay or a line segment the area in
between the triangle and the outer edge
of the circle that's called a segment so
let's do an example so you can see how
to do these problems I'll show you two
different ways to approach it okay so
this one we're trying to find the area
of this segment right here the dashed
area so first thing you want to do is
want to find the area of the sector
which is that pizza slice that section
of the circle so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at the equation
of a circle PI R squared okay what we're
going to do is we're going to multiply
by 120 degrees divided by 360 okay now
why 120 degrees divided by 360 well this
is actually this region right here this
if I can draw it right here for us this
region right here is actually one-third
of the entire area of the circle so I'm
just taking the ratio of the central
angle 120 degrees divided by the whole
circle 360 degrees to get the area of
just this section that sector okay so if
we continue that on we have here 1/3
times PI 4 squared okay so that's this
area here now what we want to do is we
want to subtract off this triangle right
here okay so if we
that triangle let's look at what we have
we have a hundred and twenty degrees
this is four and this is four because
these are both the radii of the circle
okay so with me so far
and we want to subtract off this area
now there's a formula you can use and
it's one-half a B sine C so a and B are
the side lengths that make up the sides
of this triangle and angle C is the
angle that's in between the two radii
there okay so in between the two sides
so we can use this formula or what we
can do is we can subdivide this triangle
okay into two triangles so what I'm
doing is I'm dropping a perpendicular
like so okay now what I have is I have
see if I can blow this up here a little
bit larger for us is a 60-degree angle
okay like so this is four this is 30
this is 90 so we have a 30-60-90 special
right triangle so if the hypotenuse is
for the side across from the 30-degree
angle that's going to be two okay and
then the one across from the 60-degree
angle that's going to be two square root
of three okay this triangle is the exact
same so this will also be two square
root of three so what we have is we have
the base which is four square roots of
three times the height which is two
times one half okay so that's the base
times the height times 1/2 gives us the
area of this triangle so that's going to
be four square root of three because the
two and the one-half cancel so all we
have to do now is take this the area of
the sector okay this whole pie slice
minus the area of the triangle which is
four square root of three and that's
going to give you an exact answer that's
going to give us the area of the segment
just this little piece right here so you
can either use this formula I was
mentioned before or you can use the
method of just splitting the triangle in
half by dropping a perpendicular let's
look at this real quick this is one half
four times four times the sine of 120
sine of 120 is square root 3 over 2 this
is going to give you 16 times one half
which is eight and you can see the 8 and
the two
reduced to four square root of three so
either way you're going to get the same
result whichever way you want to do it
is is going to work for you so I hope
you're enjoying these videos subscribe
to the channel check out some of my past
videos and I'll see you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon